梶谷健人さん、他2名の新作が届きました
フォロー中のクリエイターの新作です！
梶谷健人
同じ「壊して建てる」なのに、なぜ伊勢神宮は讃えられ、日本の再かいはつは批判されるのか。
あるいは、エーアイ時代の正しいアンラーンについて
しがらみ
朝の呟き　2026年8月4日火　真夏
給与明細買取屋さん公式note
関関同立に入ったが母親の過干渉で人生がぶっ壊れた障害者雇用枠フルリモ週4バイト女の黒塗りなしバージョン
きょうのあなたにおすすめの記事が届いています！
[EN]山口揚平　Yohei Yamaguchi[/EN]
健康学　〜フィジカルキャピタル（健康資産）最大化のための統合学〜
BigShip |  ひとり法人2期目
フリーコンサルとして案件に入って変わったこと | ひとり法人で生きていく
Kengo KOSAKAI
個人開発専業日記：気分が極端に落ち込んでいる
[EN]高広伯彦（Ph.D. of Management Science）[/EN]
価値があると思ってるからこそ、タダで欲しがる人たち
SmartHR人事制度部
制度で解くか、運用で解くか──人事制度の見直しを半年検証した結論
牛尾　剛
人生の運を半分使って、勝間和代さんと対談できた話
久松剛
求人は過去最高、なのに倍率は頭打ち ― IT転職しじょうの10年で本当に起きていたこと
梶谷健人
エーアイ時代に個人開発者は「次のYouTuber」になるのか。
成功事例に見る構造的な類似と決定的な違い
dora_e_m
戦略から目を背けない。
〜「エンジニアリング戦略の作り方」を読んで〜
すてぃお
「出揃ってから学ぶ」が、いちばん難しい。
もっと見る
ヘルプ /
利用規約
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。